on c-span ii television for serious
readers
good evening everyone i'm katie meditor
stober the director of reader services
for kansas city public library thank you
for joining us tonight for one of our
signature events celebrating women's
history month when women invented
television with jennifer armstrong now i
like my job at kcpl and not for the
stereotypical reasons you may think
i do not read all day reading is
definitely part of my job and it's one
of the best things about my job but this
tonight is the other best thing meeting
authors of books i love and hearing them
talk about their books
but if i had to trade jobs with anyone
i'd trade jobs with jennifer armstrong
she worked at my favorite magazine
entertainment weekly for 10 over 10
years
i've read her commentary in reviews
she's written six other books on
television on pop and pop culture two of
them on shows i kind of grew up on the
mickey mouse club and sex and the city
you've probably flipped through
jennifer's most well-known book the
backstory behind the scenes compendium
seinfeldia
in her latest book when women invented
television jennifer does a deeper dive
behind the people and industry that
brought us television show business
it should come as no surprise that women
were some of the most creative
innovative and business savvy members of
in the members in the early days of
television
yet as it happens for some folks that is
the case it does come as a surprise
i'm sure everyone out there in our own
screen land recognizes the name betty
white but have you heard of erna
phillips hazel scott or gertrude byrne
if you've ever been hooked on a soap
opera you have earned a phillips to
thank
ever see alicia keys play two pianos at
the same time
key saw hazel scott do that on her
variety show
and every wise meddling mother on
television owes some small debt to
gertrude berg
tonight jennifer is going to keep the
spotlight on these four women who made
extraordinary contributions to
development of the television industry
and lasting impacts on how and what we
watch now
and if my introduction is all you needed
to start reading when women invented
television jennifer and i hope you order
it from bookshop.org or your favorite
independent bookstore
if you use bookshop.org then you know
that bookshop.org supports local
independent bookstores with every
purchase and tonight if you're using
bookshop.org
please point your purchase to jennifer's
favorite independent bookstore mcnally
jackson books in new york city and now
please welcome jennifer armstrong
thank you for having me
jennifer before we
jump into discussing the women in the
book i have to ask you to talk a little
bit about this
fascination obsession that we were
talking about in the green room with
television and popular culture
how did you turn everyone's favorite
sport channel surfing into a career
i was really lucky i will admit that
right now um i grew up in a really pop
culture centric household i didn't
realize this until you know maybe
college and and beyond when i met other
people who didn't know everything to
there was to know about pop culture like
i did but there was always records
playing or the tv on or we were going to
the movies together i have a lot of
memories with my family
of you know going to see raiders of the
lost ark with my dad or sleepless in
seattle with my mom or watching the mary
tyler moore show with both of them and
we would quote things and you know so
this is
clearly where it started um tv in
particular i always tell this nerdy
story about myself i was such a nerd i
have many of these but this is one
when i was a kid we'd get tv guide you'd
still get the actual tv guide in the
mail
and we're talking i'm just like 10 years
old or something we would get it and
what i would do is i'd read all the
articles and then i would go through the
whole week and circle all the things i
was going to watch that week and then
i was ready so that just shows you like
it's it's not a huge leap to realize
that eventually i end up working at
entertainment weekly writing articles
like those ones i just remember thinking
like who gets to do this and why and how
um i did go to journalism school and my
early career was actually totally not
like this i was a newspaper for a local
newspaper reporter going to like city
council meetings writing four stories a
day about the police beat and the city
council beat and things like that but
eventually i did make my way to new york
city where i am now
um with kind of i remember actually
telling my um journalism professor in
college when he said what's your dream
job i actually did say i said
entertainment weekly or rolling stone
and i
cannot believe that i actually made it
there it's crazy i still almost can't
believe it and it was already 10 years
ago that i left
but um you know just kind of through
various channels kept plugging away
and they actually did hire me because of
my newspaper career they loved that i
knew how to report how to actually be a
reporter
and
from there kind of worked my way up and
that was a life-changing job for me
i was there for 10 years like you
mentioned it's where all of my
inspiration and work and friends and
everything came from and i'm so so
grateful i mean we were just talking
about grey's anatomy before we started
and i got to be on the set of grey's
anatomy at its heights you know all the
time i was there constantly
um you know it like i was just i was
in hawaii on the set of lost when lost
was at its peak i was so so lucky and
that is really where i started to focus
on television and mostly women in
television and so that kind of starts to
lead me toward writing books about
television um i had an opportunity
essentially to write the book that you
mentioned about the mickey mouse club
and that was when i first realized like
oh what if you could write a whole book
about one show like it's a biography but
it's about a show
and um
from there i wrote books about the
murray tyler moore show seinfeld and sex
in the city and here we are so
and i had always wanted to be an author
really in the grand scheme of things
what i really wanted was to write books
so i finally got to sort of marry those
two aspects of myself
that sounds so
so fascinating and so lucky i'm so
envious that you've got to be on the set
for lost and grey's anatomy i always
think i would have i would have lost it
if i were there
i loved i loved lost so much that was so
good such a brain bender it really was
it really was i was there right before
they opened the hatch it was really
exciting
everybody out there watching knows
exactly which i'm talking about
so for your book though when women
invented television
it couldn't have been easy to narrow
down the list so tell us how you came to
this subject
and these women in particular because
i'm sure there were many women who could
have held a place between these covers
absolutely and the point of the book was
actually
um to show
that there was this time between 1948
and 1955 when women did a lot more than
you might think and then that it is
remembered and what happened was i
stumbled on this little piece of history
because i was working on my book about
the mary tyler moore show mary and lou
and rhoda and ted
and um whenever i do a book about a show
i find i generally have to go back at
least a good 20 years in tv history to
kind of understand what led up to it
right and why it was a big deal and one
um there were two things that happened
in that research that kind of piqued my
interest and then i filed them away
until years later
and those two things were one was that i
asked the creators of the show james l
brooks and alan burns about the
inspirations for the character of rhoda
who was mary's best friend and was also
overtly jewish
and they named a number of big jewish
characters from both literature and
television
in the past and one of the one of the
influences that came up was gertrude
berg and i i just thought i have no idea
who that is i don't know what that is
and so they told me a little bit then i
googled it later and i got fascinated
instantly because she was incredibly
famous at this time she was really had
the first successful family sitcom
and
you cannot overstate it's like there's
many ways i can tell you she was voted
the most trusted woman in america after
eleanor roosevelt she had a line of
house dresses she had a cookbook that
was successful she had a column where
she gave motherly advice
she this show was the first show that
was so successful on television it was
made into a movie like everyone knew i
even interviewed someone who worked with
her on the movie um who played a young
woman in the movie at the time and she
is still with us and i asked did you
know who gertrude berg was when you were
gonna do the movie and she said oh honey
everybody know who knew who gertrude
berg was
um
so that just tells you like this woman
was incredibly famous and i didn't know
i had never heard of her so that was the
first thing that kind of like i filed a
way in my head
and the second thing from the mary tyler
moore show research was that um we were
talking about the character that betty
white played on the mary tyler moore
show which was suanne nivens the happy
homemaker she um
great character and great performance
she
was this character who had like a
homemaking show on the station where
mary worked and she was this very sweet
sort of sickly sweet character in front
of the camera and were these frilly
dresses and the minute the camera went
off she was
a different person um
she was cutting and mean and hilarious
and so the first part of that character
the sickly sweet part what they said is
they said you know before we even cast
betty we had described her in the in the
script as a betty white type
and i thought i have no idea what you
mean you know i didn't know her until
the 70s and this character so
i was like i what is that and so i
looked it up and it did turn out this
was really a joke about her character
from the 40s and 50s when she would be
on
um she was on a los angeles daytime talk
show and she indeed was just
the sweetest thing and that was kind of
her deal and you liked it or you didn't
but that was the way it was and she did
wear these frilly dresses with high
necklines
and um so it really i was like how
interesting and that one really led me
to actually kind of do a little more
research and reading about
tv at that time and i did start bumping
into
all of these women doing things and i
thought wow i had no idea and that was
really how i came to
this idea and then from there made a
gigantic list
where i then started to narrow down and
with throughout the book i mentioned a
number of other women in like a
paragraph or two just to at least
you know give a nod to them um
so there were lots of women who i didn't
quite make it into the narrative i
thought four was about right i went with
the sex and the city rule and the golden
girls rule that you know a foursome is
about what we can handle and you have
different i want wanted different
experiences of that and i wanted to show
i figured if i could get four the four
different experiences from these women
it would kind of show the whole picture
so i had you know betty white and erna
phillips who worked in daytime and i had
hazel scott and gertrude berg who worked
in prime time i had hazel and gertrude
who worked in new york and betty who was
working in los angeles they all had
different family
situations betty was very very single
the other you know um hazel and gertrude
were married with children erna was
unmarried but had adopted two children
on her own so i was kind of trying to
like show in different genres and so
there were women like faye emerson um
who was had a hugely successful
nighttime talk show um
which i think that's shocking too you
know just because we don't know you know
we know about milton berle for instance
every
mr television he's fine but you know
it's crazy to me
that we know his name so well
this far out but we don't know women
like that or amanda randolph who was a
black woman who had
her own talk show in daytime and also
was actually the first i believe i'm
getting this right the first um
the first black woman to be the star of
a sitcom so you know there's there's
a lot of women who worked behind the
scenes in front of the camera all of
that stuff but i wanted to show the
complete experience and also really have
four women who
very much contributed
to their genre you know who actually i
wanted to call it when women invented
television so i wanted them all to have
some
sense of that invention in their career
sorry let's go back to gertrude berg
then and
i'm going to ask
the picture to come back up and
talk to us about gertrude's
contributions to tv because you said
that she was
a household named he was a business
conglomerate martha stewart probably
took cues from gertrude burr
exactly i think of martha and oprah when
i think of her
um very much ahead of her time all these
women were in their own ways she was a
workhorse first of all um this woman
loved to work she loved what she did she
lived for especially this character
molly goldberg um quintessential jewish
mother character she created her
for
radio and was actually on the radio with
the goldbergs her show which by the way
is no relation to the current sitcom the
goldbergs um the goldbergs was on for 17
years
on the radio
and what i love about this is this woman
looked at that and said that's not
enough for me
um she had kind of just wound down at
what i call kind of a sitcom lifetime
right you you have children on a sitcom
they eventually grow up and move out of
the house
um she had lived a sitcom life time and
then some
she actually did a broadway version
briefly right after it ended because she
did not want it to end on the radio and
then tv was coming up and so she really
used broadway as this dry run because
she saw she had such vision she saw that
this was there was there was something
gonna happen over in those in that tv
world
and this is like 1948
so she just thought my god i can reboot
this thing to speak in modern terms you
know i can start this over and start out
with you know a young
with a preteen and a teenager on my show
and do a whole other sitcom lifetime
and so at the age of 50 having had
incredible success already she just used
that power and basically i start my book
with this but she kind of marched into
the office of cbs
um
and william paley the the head of cbs
and said and this was a powerful man he
was he was the guy at the time um she
marched right in there and she said
i think i deserve a spot on your
television network i i got you through
the depression on radio
and you owe me
and he thought about it for a little
while she had actually been rejected by
all the other networks including him
once
and she was not taking that she was not
taking no for an answer so she demanded
this and he said all right let's try it
um and that is how the goldberg started
so
she and this is very like
this is the kind of thing that goes on
for her over and over throughout her
career she really was so dedicated to
work and to this character i think in
particular and in some ways it you know
it eventually turned out to be somewhat
of a downfall for her
that she was so dedicated to this but um
really just like you know such a
powerful woman and knew it and
was not afraid to use this especially
behind the scenes in in public she
really presented this image of america's
mother
um behind the scenes she loved to dress
beautifully
she did not cook and yet she put out a
line of house dresses that would cost
like a dollar fifty
and
um had a successful cookbook so you know
she was also
a master of her image
goldberg's isn't a show that i recall
seeing as a kid in constant reruns
so can you tell us a little bit about
her show what was the premise and
and were able to interview any of the
actors in the show
yeah absolutely what do they remember
um
so the goldbergs was
um
about a family living in a a jewish
family living in a bronx tenement
and that's kind of it that's why it's
this is the quintessential one of the
first
family sitcoms and if you watch the
early episodes you that is what you
would call it that's what you recognize
it as it really sets that up so
you know the classic kind of we're in
the living room
cute problems happen
mom helps to solve them
in
20 to 30 minutes you know and um the big
hallmarks of the show just to give you a
visual sense first of all it's always
these are live shows so they would do
this live even though it's a scripted
sitcom that's just the way television
worked that's the technology of the time
um so it cut it it makes for some mad
cap kind of things that they need to do
it's very by the seat of your pants diy
she would have to wear like three
dresses
layered and run out take a dress off
she's got a new one on it's a new day
the next scene
um she had this signature that she
started on radio but people went
absolutely crazy for on television which
is she had one of the first tv
catchphrases she
the tenement she would have there was a
window in their apartment and it looked
out on an air shaft and she would lean
out the window and yell yoo-hoo mrs
bloom
and the neighbor would come out pop her
head out the window and we would see
them gossip at the window and you hooing
was a big thing sometimes the husband
the tv husband would be like
you know molly they're yoohooing for you
um it was like their telephone system so
that was a really big like people knew
that and the other thing she did that
was really incredible is she
would deliver
the ads in character
she wrote them herself so sanka coffee
was her first sponsor and these ads are
riveting i'm telling you it's like my
favorite part of the show
um she would start out at the window in
the beginning of the show
and she just started telling you a story
in her character's voice which was very
natural sometimes she'd stutter a little
all of this stuff
and you'd think like i don't know where
she's going with this she started
telling a story about like we went to
the catskills to try to get away
everybody there
you know was really tired though they
weren't sleeping well they were very
irritable and you're thinking like what
is she doing and then she'd be like i
told them about saying coffee which is
decaffeinated instant coffee 95 of the
sleep or 95 of the caffeine is taken out
but the sleep is left in
um
and then she turned around and start her
[ __ ] like she'd turn around to her
family they would have been bustling
around back behind her and she just
start you know from there she would turn
right around and often she would link
even the story from the sangha
commercial right into okay we just got
back from the catskills we're all you
know unpacking now um and that this was
a huge hit she was she sold incredible
amounts of sanka and this too you know
just enhanced her her power in these
early days
i think you just yeah i think you just
solved a home mystery for me why was
there so much sanka in my house when i
was a kid i'm pretty certain that's
where it came from
pretty certain my grandmother is the one
that brought it over
yeah well the sleep is left in so that's
all you need to know 95 of the
caffeine's removed and the sleep is left
in
and those coffee crystals i remember
those two oh yes
we're showing our age we don't want to
do that
so let's um let's move on to the next
character i was just
gobsmacked at how beautiful the hazel
scott is and how talented and her story
is
heartbreaking and inspiring and i was
enamored that alicia keys paid homage to
hazel scott so please tell us about
hazel's
show and
what is she doing in this photo and
she's just amazing
her famous first she really really is i
keep describing her as the beyonce of
her day um for a number of reasons
um look at how glamorous she is i this
dress i can't everything the looks were
always on point um
this woman knew how to put herself
together she's beautiful
she was a big star and she had
a couple of big tricks that she did that
people really loved as a jazz performer
one is this she would play two pianos at
once and like you said alicia keys did
this a few years ago when she hosted the
emmys and i was so excited because i was
already writing this book i was
screaming and like running around the
apartment going i just want to tell
someone she just said hazel scott
um which i just loved and the other
thing that hazel did is she she
swung the classics so she would start
out playing like a
traditional box song or whatever and
then as it went on she'd kind of make it
jazzier and jazzier and super cool and
this is you know the height of of jazz
at the time so this people love this she
was selling out concert halls across the
country um using her platform to
um advance civil rights was a big issue
for her and so for instance she would
not play segregated venues she would
walk out if she walked in and saw the
red carpet down the middle
separating the two sides she'd walk
right back out and she would give you
know interviews then and say
i don't know why someone would want to
pay to see someone who looks like me
play but wouldn't want to sit next to
someone who looks like me
so she was this great
figure and advocate and really used her
platform for that another big thing
about her is that she was married to
adam clayton powell jr
a
congressman from harlem who was his own
gigantic star i mean
very charismatic
gorgeous
debonair he was a preacher
um they had met in harlem she saw him
preach he saw her perform it was all on
um and they actually had kind of a
scandalous beginning because he was
still
married at the time so all of this just
adds to their mystique right i mean they
were in ebony magazine all the time
there's one incredible cover story about
them where it's like a beautiful photo
of them with their
son skipper at the time and the headline
is my life with hazel scott by
adam clayton powell jr and he wrote all
about how
wonderful their lives were together she
cooks she makes chocolate cake
she plays the piano she's gorgeous
um you know it was that kind of thing so
that's why i think of her as kind of the
beyonce of her day and naturally for
good for all of those reasons um
the doom network which was the fourth
network at the time
um
offered her the chance to have her
own variety show in
prime time and so she had the show first
it was just in new york city where she
lived and she loved this because she
could finally stay home with her son
most of the time instead of traveling
all over the country to perform
and um it was so popular it expanded to
multiple nights a week in new york and
then finally it um expanded nationally
and it actually made her the first black
person to have
a prime time show
that was national um
and this was 1950. so really big deal
and you know mention segregation this is
still jim crow south this is still
of you know an incredible time to be
making this kind of breakthrough
and um unfortunately it's it burns
bright and fast because she ran into the
blacklist the hollywood blacklist um she
was listed in this publication named red
channels that claimed to
be telling you who might be a communist
they didn't say they were they said
these people might be do what you want
um and she as you sort of alluded to i
think heroically
volunteered to go before the house on
american activities committee because
she wanted she thought she could clear
her name by doing this but
really what she was doing is
is standing up for what was right and
she really gave this incredible rousing
speech
um she was very good with words
and um
it's just it's so if it's hard to
overstate you know this black woman
going before these white men
in power and
explaining to them what they're doing
wrong
um and she's completely right
and
really just it's it's such an incredible
story and unfortunately
um i want it to be different i want the
movie to go differently and to have
everyone rally behind her and go like we
can't take this anymore let's boycott
everyone who fires people because of
you know possible communist
implied communist ties but instead she
goes back home to new york and kind of
soon afterwards
is very unceremoniously
um
fired i mean they don't really say it
that way they can't find a sponsor all
of a sudden for her show
it goes off the air
and she was very disillusioned and
moved to paris not that long afterwards
because she felt like like there were a
number of uh black american expatriates
in paris at the time like james baldwin
and she felt like the reception there
was much better for her and so i think
that all goes a long way toward telling
us why we maybe don't
know her name and certainly don't know
her contribution to television because
those tapes are lost there's no we can't
find the recordings
and that is a just a travesty
i'm rolling back just a little bit to
ask did her husband congressman powell
was he
any help or was that a bit of a
hindrance in that situation
yeah i suspect it was a hindrance i
suspect it all goes together you can't
prove any of these things with this
stuff including the firing right they
tried to like sue later and it was so
hard to prove definitively what caused
what his her husband you know
as her son tells it anyway her you know
she came home and said i'm gonna go talk
to them and he was like please don't
because he knew what was gonna happen
but she really couldn't she couldn't
stand by which i think is so admirable
um
he had a number of enemies in congress i
think for overtly racial reasons
and um you know i have a story in the
book
uh that they they found out they were
being wiretapped
when they were
you know going abroad for his trips they
found out the their own fbi was
wiretapping them which was a very common
practice they did this to martin luther
king jr too
um you know so
i think that
it probably contributed it probably made
her a target in addition to her
you know they did a lot of civil rights
work together
and
you know she is also just a black woman
and then she's got this tv show too in
addition to being in music and they were
really common for tv at that time
because they were obviously already
scared of the power the tv was going to
have and what really started to happen
was that this list came out and then a
woman
named jeanne muir got successfully fired
from a show that she was on because she
was on the list and once that happened
there was sort of this free-for-all of
like who can we figure out how to get
rid of next and so the advertisers are
very emboldened to demand that these
suspected communists be fired
that's terrible advertising just
deciding no we don't like your politics
doesn't matter that your show is going
through the roof and the ratings
yeah which is crazy i don't i the
business of this i actually don't
understand and i the only the only
explanation i have is hysteria because
the business end makes no sense right
she's doing great so why would you do
that except that it's emotional it's
racism and sexism
and fear
all freaking out all of a sudden i mean
we didn't talk about this yet but
basically a messier version of this not
messier you know for the person but
messier in terms of more complicated
version of this happens to gertrude berg
her tv husband philip loeb was on the
same list with hazel scott and um
general foods who made cenka
um loved her commercials her commercials
were revolutionary but all of a sudden
you know they demanded she fired phillip
loeb and she refused it first and this
kept the show off the air right when it
was hitting at peak
it had just had its movie version happen
all of the stuff it was supposed to come
back in the fall and be paired with this
new show called i love lucy
and instead it got pulled off the air
again very unceremoniously when it was
in the top ten they said it was for
budgetary reasons but when i looked at
the budgets it was
it was very similar budget wise to
less popular shows of its kind and you
know really that broke the momentum of
her show and of her career so she was
off the air for a while she was able to
get it back on the air on nbc a little
bit later
but still ended up having to fire philip
globe or stop the show altogether and
all of those things it's like they were
off the air for a while and then i
believe having watched the show she and
philip globe had that special chemistry
that we recognize in you know tv stars
will they won't they type tv stars now
um they were really special they seemed
like a married couple they seemed really
lived in and had a connection and so
then she she ends up replacing him twice
because he's so hard to replace the
first one doesn't stick
the second one he's fine but i never i
don't like the later episodes with him
nearly as much as i like the earlier
episodes with philip loeb and so all
together this just this is why i think
we don't know
not everyone knows about gertrude berg
either and they're similar to hazel the
recordings of the show they do exist but
especially the early versions which are
the best the early episodes which are
the best ones they're a very bad version
they're kind of like a copy of a copy so
i think that's why we see like an isle
of lucy in
endless reruns because it was this is
getting nerdy now but they they shot on
film
for um i love lucy whereas the goldbergs
was still live and so it was just a bad
photo bad copy of the show and so i
believe that this is a huge you know
factor in the end of
lucy is a legend and she should be and
she was a genius but i also think they
made this critical decision to film um
to shoot on film and thus preserve
themselves into the streaming era even
they didn't even think about that i bet
that's something that crossed gertrude's
mind at some point
she seems so
yeah and hazel it's so so innovative and
it's almost as if their innovation their
their drive and their independence
is what the industry didn't like to see
even though the industry benefited so
much from it oh completely and i mean
there are known kind of correlations too
between the blacklist and working women
um in addition to the obvious factor
which is that we have a black woman and
a jewish woman so i think it's
fascinating to you that they went after
gertrude's tv husband i mean part of it
is just that he had the right
resume as it were you know if if you
hung out in certain places they could
kind of go after you so he and hazel
actually both hung out at a place called
cafe society where hazel played
and um was a real lefty hangout and that
actually got shut down by the blacklist
um but also he was a big labor activist
so they could go after him but i also
think it was an interesting way to go
after gertrude right because she was so
popular and beloved what if we kind of
just go at her from the side here and
demand that this lady listen to us and
do what we say and get rid of this guy
and see if see if it works you know um
and i really think
that all of those factors came into play
there
women in power
can be scary yeah
so let's talk a little bit about um
erna phillips who is my favorite out of
this book and you know why
her contributions to
to
soap operas but
she's
she's amazing and she's quiet and not
quite but this is a name i did not know
until i encountered it in your book
i could see where
i might have learned a little bit about
hazel scott and gertrude berg in my
classes in communications but not erna
phillips what did she do with her life
that turned it into tv gold
she is i mean i feel like i say this at
all i'm like what a powerhouse um and
she's my only woman who was really just
behind the scenes she was not in front
of the camera she invented the daytime
soap opera um she did it for radio
because her bosses asked her to make
something just you know sell stuff to
women
and
um yeah it's all it's all comes notice
notice what we keep coming back to the
ads right that's what it all comes down
to in both radio and television and so
she made these little domestic dramas
that was what she came up with she by
the way did not like the term soap opera
till
you know her entire life she used um
cereal as as it's a serialized drama
that's what it is and it was called soap
operas because they wanted to sell soap
to the ladies
and it was a denigrating term and i can
tell you she endured lots of bad reviews
and i'm not saying that because she was
bad at her job i'm saying because it was
men writing reviews about this stuff and
they were all like what's with these
whiny women with their problems at home
um and she
you know did some really key things that
we would still recognize in in terms of
the form it's like the organ the
dramatic organ cues for when there's
drama right and the dramatic pause she
loved a dramatic pause and was often
demanding that her writers and directors
use more dramatic pauses which i love
and um also just really key use of
cliffhangers which um you and i were
talking about you know shonda rhimes
before this and um i think of that and i
think of just anything we watch on
netflix now when we binge watch how
we're so dependent on that cliffhanger
that's how she kept her audience coming
back day after day
in the daytime and so she was she was
very good at knowing her audience
um she knew things down to like you have
to tell the story at a certain pace
because the women might be doing their
housework while watching and you don't
want to like make it so dependent on
just seeing it that they'll miss
something
um
and she brought the form from radio to
television she actually the first
daytime soap opera ever on television
which was called these are my children
which is no relation to all my children
um
that was a flop but it was the first one
and so that's we learn along the way
and then um eventually came back with
um a very successful idea which was she
brought her
massive hit radio soap opera
the guy it was the guiding light at the
time
and um very this i love this detail of
this they brought it they brought it to
tv in this very specific way which was
they they kept the show right going they
kept it just the plot line just kept
going
from radio to tv and then it was
simulcast on radio and television so you
could listen to the actors doing it or
see them
for a time and that was how she kind of
had this really big hit to the point
where it lasted until not that long ago
and was the longest running broadcast
show in history because it actually
predated television and you know in
radio and then came to television so she
then went on to have lots of other
successful shows and mentored lots of
people who went into um
the same business went into soap operas
as well so she almost kind of had her
fingerprints on most shows on telev on
in daytime soaps at one point um so she
is just another one where um really
incredibly successful
and was doing this while uh raising two
children that she adopted on her own as
a single woman
did she work any of her own life into
her
serialized drama plots she sure did how
about this is another really big thing
that i think is an actual contribution
to the genre if you think about it the
adoption plot line
she was constantly going to her own
experience with adoption in a million
different ways whether it was the
surprise reveal
you were adopted or the surprise reveal
of this is your real father
um there were she had so many different
variations on this she had one that was
kind of heartbreaking um
where she had a teenage character who
said something like um
you know if i ever meet my birth mother
i'm gonna kill her and i believe it is
that she ends up doing it in the show
her daughter had said something like
that to her
um her kids were often acting out and
using the adoption against her
and um she felt very guilty about her
mothering and at one point said that she
actually regretted
um adopting her children she was very
very concerned about the fact that she
could not give them a father and this
haunted her
and so another thing that she did in her
soaps where this really came out you
know where there was this interplay is
that she started
deliberately making strong male
characters she had started out with
really strong women in her early shows
some of her early radio stuff was just
women
and
eventually in the 50s interestingly
enough along with the rest of the
country as it goes super patriarchal she
really took it in and felt guilty and
started saying i'm going to write
strong men and strong marriages because
i feel personally responsible for
the the rising divorce rate and also
that i think there needs to be more
strong male role models in the world
because i wasn't she wasn't able to give
that to her
kids and especially her son that really
haunted her and so this really she
really worked out a lot of stuff in her
own work
wow
tell me she's not the one who gave us
um amnesia and evil twin
that was going on i mean it was in the
ether i'm not sure if she did but it was
already in the ether on like the radio
stuff they were already talking about
the ridiculous you know she really it's
interesting though just as a touchstone
touch point on this you know she started
when she started these they were very
grounded it was like very normal stuff
at first it was can i borrow your dress
for this wedding i have to be in and
what shoes am i going to wear and does
this man love me and
this sort of thing they were often set
in boarding houses and it would be
that's how she would have women who were
not necessarily related interacting with
each other
um and then it you know i think what
happened is quickly if you're doing a
daytime
a daily show you start to realize like i
gotta
snap this up and so they start to really
escalate and something she did actually
bring to the genre is the idea of having
like doctors and lawyers she was very
into doctor well she was into both
actually and she had a lot of doctors
and lawyers in her own life so i think
this is telling but she she actually is
a contributor to something like grey's
anatomy in the sense that she saw how
if you had a doctor like on the guiding
light she had um a pastor
so what that allowed was people could
come to the pastor with problems
and that means it made more sense that
they were having constant dramatic
problems because they were coming to him
with problems and same thing with
something like a doctor of course
there's they see stuff because they're a
doctor so she kind of brought this idea
of the professional
as a conduit of drama
that is
that just makes me think about some of
my favorite shonda shows in a totally
different light exactly exactly
well i saved i think what some folks
will consider the best for last to ask
you about betty white and all of us
who think about betty white now we
probably the first thing we think about
is betty white the feisty senior citizen
she just turned 100
and
her snicker bar
football commercials are just their
comedy gold but look at this beautiful
vibrant woman
who was a lot sharper than that su ann
character you were telling me about yes
and she was not mean um that is the part
that was not based on her at all for
every i swear to god i've never heard
anyone say anything thank god bad about
betty white and i have talked to her and
she is as delightful as you want her to
be um
but yes she was the hot young thing
in the early 50s i mean i
really loved reading these feature
stories on her at the time that really
were saying you know
this is one young woman to watch uh her
comedy timing is pretty good
that kind of thing and um she was just
incredible so she was you know as i
mentioned she was doing this talk show
in los angeles at first called hollywood
on television where she and her co-host
al jarvis were on the air five and a
half hours a day six days a week
ad-libbing it up doing whatever they
felt like sometimes it was sketches
sometimes they talk about the news
they just banter with each other they
also had to deliver all their
commercials for those five and a half
hours can you imagine um
and she liked to memorize her
commercials so that was the one part
that would be a little scripted and so
she's out there you know vacuuming stuff
up to show you about this vacuum or you
know all these kinds of crazy things
it's really fascinating um but from
there you know one of her one of their
sketches really caught on and um
she spun it off into a sitcom called
life with elizabeth
and it is delightful you can find some
clips of it on youtube and what a treat
she's there from the beginning man she
is
these are just very silly little
plotlines it's really just the they'd
have this announcer come on and he'd say
like incident number one in life with
elizabeth
and then it would be it was her just her
and her tv husband that's it it was this
duo and they would occasionally have
like maybe one or two guest stars but it
was very tight it was small and often
they would do two or three setups in one
half hour so they'd do these like 10
minute almost sketches and it would just
be like elizabeth's gonna learn how to
drive but she doesn't want to tell alvin
you know like that kind of very sit
commie
type of thing and she is hilarious and
um there's kind of this gambit they do
that's really a signature thing where
the announcer will talk directly to her
through the camera and be like elizabeth
you know what do you think you're doing
now and she would she wouldn't talk to
him but she'd like gesture and he his
signature line was he'd say elizabeth
aren't you ashamed and then she'd go
and it is the cutest thing it's so cute
um
totally recommend so that's so at one
point she had this and life you know she
had the talk show and life with
elizabeth going which is an insane
schedule
and then um
the talk show ended because she was
actually offered the chance to have a
national talk show of her own the betty
white show
and that was 1954 and so she was really
like
you know there were all these stories
that were like america's sweetheart is
here and it's betty white and you should
pay attention to her
and one of my favorite things i
mentioned her frilly dresses but um
she was known particularly for her high
necklines
because she was wanted to be very sweet
and jimmer similar i think similarly to
gertrude burke she was very much
very clear on managing her own image
and um took some flack for it sometimes
there were some i read some mean sexist
reviews of her show and that sort of
thing um where the men seemed basically
a little disappointed that she wasn't
you know trying to seduce them at all
times
and um you know people would kind of
make fun of her a little bit for being
so sweet and insipid and all that stuff
but i think she is just charming when i
watch these old clips she sang songs you
guys she sang
she wanted to be a singer she had
actually wanted started out wanting to
be an opera singer so
um she doesn't sing as much as she used
to but uh she really sang a lot back in
those days that was the thing people did
on tv
and yeah she is just absolutely
dripping with charm in these old clips
and was really this
already at that time really a powerhouse
and also very shrewd about
image management you know she dealt a
lot with
constant questions why are you single
why don't you want kids you know we're
getting into the mid 50s at that point
everyone is suspicious of that
she was actually divorced twice
before this um and was living back with
her parents after the two marriages she
didn't go she didn't bring it up in
interviews she would just say i just
don't have time for a husband right now
and i'm very smart right i just want to
give my full attention to him when i
find him but first
i have these shows to do and she didn't
talk a little bit about you know no one
would ever ask a man
why are you working so hard instead of
being married so
this is what i'm doing right now and she
was actually pretty about but at that
time she was like i'm just like i'm
never gonna get married because i i love
my career too much and that's she felt
like she had to choose between the two
at the time she later did get married
and had one of the great um hollywood
marriages to um
[Music]
al ludden um
she has a lot of alvins and owls and
things in her life um
but
she had this great um
marriage later on but she really at this
time was like absolutely not she was
really clear on what she wanted and
didn't want
i'm gonna take a moment to see if
there's a couple of questions here oh
there is
um what ground still remains to be
broken by women in tv today uh most of
the directing for example is still being
done by men isn't it
yeah and i mean i think we still have
plenty of room for improvement though
things are certainly
better than they used to be there's just
so much opportunity in streaming i think
the big challenge now is there's a lot
the numbers are a lot bigger because
every i don't know if you guys have
noticed during the pandemic especially
there is a lot of television to watch
there's it's just constant and so that's
great and that has opened up so many
more avenues so i always say now like
isn't it great how there isn't just one
or two women's shows which i think was
how it was i mean even something like
sex in the city i feel like was still
supposed to be here's here's the ladies
show all the ladies watch this right
it's like well no that's about four rich
thin white women in a very specific you
know situation a lot of people liked it
but it wasn't representing a lot of
voices now we have tons of voices the
problem is that you don't have
you're never going to have that kind of
hit again where lots and lots of people
are watching one thing we have some
phenomenon you know we've we've had a
little bit of that but a shit's creek is
not the same
as
you know a sex in the city or well it's
you know it's a little closer but or
like a seinfeld you know it's not this
big cultural moment and so it's it's
like there's more women doing stuff but
they're not ever gonna have the same
power that was sort of concentrated at a
different time in television that can
that's good in some ways because there's
something for everyone um but i think we
need to get more women in at least the
biggest you know kind of
places that we have these days i i would
say shonda rhimes is doing it but um i
would like more
more shonda rhimes
is what we really see
right
where it's this she's this powerhouse
and she can make something like
bridgerton was as close as we're gonna
get to something like a phenomenon where
even if you haven't seen it
you know what it is you were forced at
some point to be like okay what is
everyone talking about
um okay i guess it's the sexy thing with
people in a different time great now i
know um but you know that's i think more
of that level of
power more women in that in that
situation would be the next step i think
we've had a question from one of the
audience members
listening to you talk about gertrude
berg's live improvisation and her comedy
timing
what kind of presence do you think she
would have had on a show like saturday
night live oh i think of gertrude bergen
so many different i'm just like i wish
she were here um she's
so it's another one i just i mean i
recommend for all of these go watch some
clips you can find those too and she is
really interesting on camera because
you know she is not a 28 year old beauty
in the way that like uh you know uh
betty white was at the time she was not
what we think of as
she was not jennifer aniston you know um
but she is has this presence that you
would not even belie i mean my god um
nobody had a shot against her and if you
read reviews of her work which i quote a
lot in the book it's very funny because
she um
she was you know all the reviewers just
lost it when she they didn't even like
her play version of the goldbergs but
they would all be like
this is kind of a mess but my god
gertrude bird when she one of them said
something incredible she actually won a
tony later in her life for a dramatic
performance on broadway and the reviewer
at the time said something like we are
all children when gertrude berg is on
the stage
and i just thought like yep i can
totally see i mean i was never in her
presence obviously but just seeing her
on the show it's sort of she's one of
those it doesn't matter what she did you
just wanted to keep watching and having
seen her on she did a number of um
appearances on milton berle they were
really good friends her in milton berle
and um
she did a lot of appearances usually in
character as molly goldberg
and um
that is the closest we can see to her
being on like an snl
and she steals
the show from milton berle like
you don't even know anymore that it's
his show it is hilarious she completely
takes over and just
the camera is like
on her and she's just she was such a
force and that's why i mean that's why
she was such a success
i love carol i love characters like that
i love actors like that where they
redeem everything anything they're in
that's just they make they elevate
everything and if it's bad they redeem
it this is her i watched some um
i i was at the penalty center the nerdy
paley center which i love where you can
watch all sorts of stuff that you can't
get anywhere else i watched some stuff
she did like these movie of the week
what it is essentially that's the
equivalent from the time of these movie
of the week type things
and same deal it's like it didn't matter
if the script was good you were just in
because she was so and it's it really
tells you though too like she was so
married to this character molly goldberg
i think she could have gone bigger i
think she could have done
anything and was kind of doing that when
she died at a relatively early age um in
the 60s but she had two plays in the
works when she died which i love like
one was already selling had already sold
out because they were selling tickets
and she was working on another one um so
she really had had started on this sort
of second career as a broadway star when
she died
that's unfortunate like hard to think
about what it is we might have lost and
you know
i know
someone wants to know if you would uh
rank or just give us in any order the
five most powerful influential women's
characters in television history oh god
that's so hard okay actually no i can do
this um
i'm gonna go
to the easy one first because i wrote a
book about it um i'll probably do two
from my books
cross promotion but
definitely the mary tyler moore there's
no
mary richards
there's you you can't overstate this in
terms of women on television i mean you
just really can't i wrote a whole book
about her and the reason is she was so
you know her singleness her professional
you know she's a single professional
woman over 30 um having living her best
life right in front of us making us all
want to be her and this was
revolutionary at the time um she wasn't
the first single woman we had that girl
before it which was lovely and i and
super important too
but the fact that she was over 30 the
fact that she was very independent and
really as the show went on was not even
interested in dating that i mean she
dated but that was not the end game it
was really about her professional life
and you know making her way alone so she
is just you cannot overstate it
and when i was at entertainment weekly i
was often talking to women like tina fey
um mindy kaling that sort of thing and
everyone cited her as their influence
you just can't get past that um probably
lucille ball
can't get past that either i mean my
book sort of like
is all about a reaction to her right she
wasn't my book is basically saying she
wasn't the only one um but you know a
lot about her so i'll let you read about
her elsewhere i'm gonna tell you about
these women but you know i mean she is
the influence on someone like mary and
going forward what i mean and probably
the reason that women could do things in
television like this is a woman who
produced and starred in her show right
um
and then i would say let's see
trying to think
it gets harder as you go forward for the
exact reasons i was talking about you
don't have these mass hits anymore but
um
you know i think sex in the city was big
um i think carrie bradshaw was big and
she's a female anti-hero
among other things and kind of made it
so that women could be super flawed like
not just like cute how she stumbles
sometimes right but like
very very flawed character
um
i'm gonna go claire huxtable
um i know we don't like to talk about
the show anymore
um
but this is
you just cannot deny i mean 80s 80s
sitcom bombs queen of the 80s sitcoms
moms
also just seeing felicia rashad she's
still out there doing stuff all the time
and i'm
every time like
she i i think she's the star of the show
i really do i think she
takes it
um
and then i'm trying to think of a like
current you know ish like in the last 20
years i mean you could talk about tina
fey
it sort of becomes more of a like
panoply right it's like
tina fey grey's anatomy
um oh my god scandal i would she was
pretty you know that's that's olivia
pope is pretty pretty big there i would
say
so unlikeably lovable
what a mess like i mean mess in a good
way you know what i'm talking about like
what a crazy show that was like i mean
oh god and
even i'm just throwing stuff out there
now but easter
egg insecure michaela cole i may destroy
you this year i think we don't really
that one to me that like shook me i was
watching that show i don't know if
people have seen it it's a lot so it's
intense and it's okay if you don't want
to watch it too but this hbo show over
the summer that was um
sometimes comedy sometimes drama really
dark and was about a woman dealing with
her sexual assault in the aftermath
and it's incredible um it's riveting and
i what i kept thinking because i was
writing the book while reading it or
watching it and i just kept thinking my
god this would blow those women's minds
they would like if they could know i
think they'd love it but if they could
know this was where tv was going to go
not just the streaming factor but the
fact that a woman that women could do
this kind of thing and tell this kind of
story
on the medium they were in
i think that would really blow their
minds and how incredible that betty
white has been there for the whole thing
so we've got a top we've got a question
that's a little bit off topic but
one of our viewers wants to hear your
take on how kamala harris has been
portrayed on television are the news and
entertainment shows are they doing an
acceptable job of covering the first
black woman to serve as our vice
president i mean i feel i've enjoyed the
snl the snl thing is like the main thing
i think of of course and it's maya
rudolph who is perfect
um
and i really have enjoyed that uh
depiction from the beginning i feel like
it's a little bit it gets it takes us
back old school a little bit and snl
um impressions in terms of
i don't think they're trying to like
very deeply
comment on her if that makes sense like
i don't think they feel unnecessar an
urge to necessarily undercut her i'm
glad
you know that's really good i think
they're like let's just she's the main
joke is sort of like she's very
glamorous and in charge and i loved the
joke they did once that was basically
say she said something like you know
that she had been sort of made for an
nbc illegal drama and she like looked at
the camera and they had her hair blowing
um and i always think of that because
that's so accurate but it's very it's a
it's a
correctly gentle portrayal and i think
that that's really good it's respectful
um
and you know i mean i think we've we've
all heard of incidents where the news
coverage has gone less than well
um but i think a lot of places also are
still treading pretty lightly
so we'll see how it goes but it'll be
interesting i think when we get further
along too we get to a point this is
really weird but you always get to a
point with administrations where
eventually they're going to start being
portrayed do you know what i mean
there's going to be like an hbo movie
we're probably going to start to see
this with the trump administration um
and
you know the doing the sort of as
in retrospect as we start to tell it is
history i think that will be extremely
interesting too
you said something just a moment ago
that that set off
that set my brain spinning but when i
think about the tv shows that you and i
were talking about before we started and
the women that
you're talking about in this book and
even the the women that you referenced
in your previous books
you talked about
being respectful and while these women
were
certainly capable of pushing the
envelope they always did it
with some measure of
mindfulness and respectfulness of their
topics of their characters of themselves
and
and
my rudolph is being
respectful in her portrayal of
kamalaharas whereas you know there might
be elements of the news where they're
not and we know there are news shows
where
they're not
but
is that something intrinsic to the way
women
work in
mass media
is is that a good quality is it a bad
quality is it just equality with good
side bad side i mean it's probably a
good question i'm like into respect you
know what i mean like yes of course you
stand up for yourself and justice and
all of those things like hazel's a great
example right because i don't think she
was ever disrespectful um in the way
that i would describe it and you know
maybe maybe some of the white men felt
that she was but i would not describe
her that way i think she was
actually there's i talk about this in
the book a lot she was very
very conscious
of the way she portrayed herself and
often if she could
influence the way other black women were
portrayed there's a huge incident in her
career when she stops work on
a movie she was doing called the heats
on
where she had a scene where she was
playing this military song the caissons
go rolling along she was in a military
uniform like a women's you know
auxiliary uniform she looked great
but there were dancers they were all
black women in her
scene
and
they came out in their costumes that
they were given and they were dirty
aprons and she said no
that's not
that's not happening in my scene i will
not come back to work until this is
fixed she shut the production down for
days which is a lot of money and that is
not something that they enjoyed a lot um
harry kahn who was in charge of the
studio there told her she'd never work
in movies again as long as he was alive
and it was true
um but she got what she wanted they
finally gave in and gave them these
floral dresses so that just tells you
she would and she had a big thing she
would not play what she called singing
made roles
um she always had to be credited as
herself she had wardrobe approval
so she was very conscious and i think
this is still a this is a way of being
that is both respectful but also
having boundaries and similarly i think
they were all very conscious in their
own ways
gertrude's thinking about how i'm
portraying a jewish family she's also
was thinking about for instance when she
would have like a black
guest star on how she was portraying
them in her script um so i do think and
you know
betty thought about this too both with
herself
and um she had a man named arthur duncan
on her show a dancer who was black and
she brought him over she had kind of
known him from ballet and she brought
him to her national show and going
national is different you're going you
know you're suddenly going to be in the
gym south too and so she got nasty
letters and did not back down from that
and so i think that
probably as people who felt somewhat
marginalized they could always
think about other people who might be
marginalized too and
do you know they were also probably
respectful because that was you know
otherwise they were gonna just
get ousted
um if they were not respectful of
unfortunately the white men who were in
charge
but um so i think there's a little bit
of that there but i think most of them
were pretty skillful and trying to like
stand up for what they thought was right
while trying to navigate this it works
sometimes not other times
so we've been at this for a little more
than an hour and i'll close it out by
asking you
to tell us about a piece of research and
i know that you did so much research for
this book
you must have found 400 women that could
fit in this book but can you tell us
something that you had to leave out
about
any of the characters an interesting
story about erna hazel gertrude or betty
honestly the thing that comes to mind is
that i really went down this other road
with philip loeb who was blacklisted you
know who was uh gertrude's blacklisted
husband
uh tv husband and um part of that was
that actually um gertrude didn't talk a
lot about
him once she had to fire him it was very
painful
both to let him go and actually we
didn't talk about this and it is sad and
i'm sorry to have done this note but
he actually
killed himself in um
1955 he took an overdose of sleeping
pills so he died by suicide
and um was kind of known as
and like recognized as a suicide that
was due to the blacklist
and um she really did not talk about
this
and
one can understand why
um
so i was trying to figure out what
happened essentially you know what the
details were and some of them were
available but i ended up going into his
archive and um looking through his
letters as well
and he was
so funny
he was funny and very dirty they would
not they did not allow that on the
goldbergs but he had a dirty sense of
humor and if anyone is old school and
knows who zero mustel
is um big broadway star
and also sometimes film in the 60s just
really fun guy really a big big man big
presence and they were best friends and
so i found i also went into the stahl
archive and was reading zero vestal's
letters to philip loeb as he was going
through this and so much of it didn't
have to do with gertrude that i was it's
not in the book but um you know just
reading through they were such good
friends and like reading
reading men telling each other dirty
jokes in letters in the 1950s is a real
treat i highly recommend it um there
were so many i was like i'm not i'm
definitely not including that and there
was a story about how
um he once
called and was good they they invited
themselves offered it i invited him over
for dinner
and he called and asked um
something like what should i wear and oh
you know nothing don't worry about it
and he actually supposedly came over
naked um so that is the kind of guy he
was not like that around gertrude
because he knew better he was not gonna
mess around with gertrude but um he had
a really funny and dirty sense of humor
and it was it was fun to read um all of
those letters and that was definitely
like a road i did not need to go down in
the book
that's the great thing about research
all these marvelous raven holes that you
find and you just can't stop yourself
absolutely and these women also just
their lives outside you know a lot of
their story took place outside of tv so
hazel had a lot of other stuff that went
on in her life that i didn't get into as
much
um you know that kind of thing as well
because i was really focused on this
time and in television but um i highly
rec you know i recommend all the rabbit
holes with these stories because it's
very you know gertrude had a whole
lifetime on radio before i even got to
her so
just there's so much there's so much to
enjoy about their lives and it's so
inspiring to read about them
so jennifer why don't you leave us with
the name of a woman we should all
go and look up and read more about a
woman who didn't make it into your book
maybe it broke your heart to have to
leave her out i mean i think
that um faye emerson you can read about
her she was the talk show host um and
amanda randolph who i mentioned a little
bit but she was fascinating as well and
kind of had different philosophies about
roles to take and how how to manage her
career than like a hazel scott um she
actually made a joke when she got her
talk show her daytime talk show she was
paid very low i can't remember the exact
amount and someone asked her about it in
an interview and she said well for five
dollars a week what do they expect hazel
scott um so you know she
she really had a sense of humor and
seemed like a very fun woman and i
enjoyed reading about her but didn't get
all of it in there
as well
maybe the next book yeah you never know
i mean there's plenty there there really
is
well thank you so much jennifer for
spending your evening with us and
everyone if you are if you're not
enticed to read the book or you're
looking for
when women invented television
please order it from bookshop.org
or your favorite online
platform for your favorite independent
bookstore
jennifer this has been a delight we you
know that you and i could probably go on
tv
but we have to let the folks at home go
back to doing something other than
watching us maybe watching good tv
that's right
goodnight everyone and thank you so much
for joining us
book tv on c-span 2 every weekend